bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
membre de la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat vice-président de
la délégation sénatoriale aux
entreprises comment est-ce que vous
réagissez à la décision de sanofi
d'augmenter les dividendes pour cette
année hier
sanofi a fait la une de tous les
journaux puisqu'il annonce un don de 100
millions d'euros à l'hôpital public et
aux ehpad
c'est très bien mais ils ont oublié de
dire qu' il avait décidé de verser 3,95
milliards d'euros c'est à dire 3 euros
15 par action de dividendes à leurs
actionnaires
et je rappelle que sanofi bénéficient
chaque année en crédit d'impôt recherche
de 130 millions d'euros
donc en réalité la première entreprise
française du médicament dans cette crise
sanitaire décide de verser des
dividendes aux actionnaires je pense que
c'est ce n'est pas acceptable est
véritablement l'appel de bruno le maire
n'est pas entendue donc il faut
légiférer il faut faire comme d'autres
pays par exemple au danemark où on a
interdit aux entreprises de touche et de
verser des dividendes aux actionnaires
en ces temps de crise
cet argent il faut le mobiliser il faut
le mobiliser pour nos vies et non pas
pour les actionnaires
le gouvernement n'est donc pas assez
dure jusque là avec ces entreprises qui
bénéficient des publics mais qui ne
respectent pas les demandes de ne pas
verser les dividendes alors attention
parce qu' un certain nombre
d'entreprises vaut si par exemple vous
êtes comme la fnac
si vous vous demandez les plaies de près
de garanties de l'état
l'arnaqué la première grande entreprise
à l'avoir fait à hauteur de 500 millions
d'euros vous ne pouvez pas verser de
dividende à vos actionnaires à puis
d'autres groupes comme edf elle
giraudeau s'apprend ou airbus ont fait
le choix de ne pas verser
mais si vous ne bénéficiez pas bénéficié
pas du chômage partiel du prêt garanti
vous pouvez verser des dividendes aux
actionnaires et donc je pense qu'il faut
dans ces temps de crise que tout le
monde
abondent je dirais pour l'hôpital public
pour les ehpad pour nos vies et donc il
serait simple de dire que toutes les
grandes entreprises doit pas verser en
2020 de dividendes à leurs actionnaires
et puis il y à un certain nombre de cas
comme vivendi qui décide de verser 695
millions d'euros de dividendes à ses
actionnaires
sauf que ses filiales comme canal+ où
vivent 1 10 villages elles font appel au
chômage partiel
donc si les filiales fort appel au
chômage partiel la maison mère ne doit
pas pouvoir verser de dividende à ses
actionnaires un dividende non plus alors
à vous entendre pour les entreprises qui
sont elles moins touchés par la crise
actuelle c'est-à-dire moins touchés par
exemple si on reprend le cas quand même
de sanofi c'est une véritable question
que la première entreprise française du
médicament
je dirais soit solidaire dans ces temps
de crise par exemple cela repose
question est-ce qu'il faut sortir un
certain nombre de pans entiers de notre
économie du secteur marchand comme
l'avait dit le président de la
république moi je le pense et il par
exemple sur les questions d'énergie de
transport mais aussi du médicament qui
dans ces temps de crise mais aussi en
temps normal doit être un produit de
première nécessité et ça repose la
question d'un pôle public du médicament
je ne crois pas que franchement verser
des dividendes sur les médicaments ces
temps de crise soit quelque chose
d'acceptable merci beaucoup fabien gay
ça n'intéressait fin de la seine saint
denis